so have you uh you think you've
acclimated Japan now then it's like over
year now I think I need more time
actually you think you need more time I
mean it took a long time even UK where I
felt like oh yeah everything's set up
I'm good we didn't go to Greg so you
didn't
accl just let's just be real okay that's
a side quest you never fin you didn't
got go back I'll bring you on I'll never
go to gr that [__] look so
bad
pocket d
what's uh so like so why don't you feel
like you acclimate like what do I mean
what some yeah like I'm still trying to
figure out the town hall to be honest
okay yeah don't worry that's something
you'll never figure out that's part of
the acclamation process figed out fig
out yeah the day you'll remember it is
when you'll going to go collect your
pensions like that's the day you'll
figure it out yeah there's still news
that I'm like oh I have to do that and I
need this paper yeah so you know what do
you have the my number card do you have
that no and why would I I don't get it
what the [__] is that it's basically
like no so there are benefits to it it's
like a social security card Japan what's
wrong with my actual car uh SLP no the z
z it's different it's different so the
basically cuz Japan is they realize
we're like huh guys we've [__] up here
we have so many different things all on
different paper and computer systems
that are not joining over why don't we
make one card that is allows you to
access all of them in one go oh and so
they had this they made the system but a
lot of old people didn't want to do it
because like I don't want the government
my so lot people didn't do it but there
are benefits to it which you can do
which one thing that I absolutely love
if you ever need to print off documents
or documents you need to go to the City
Hall to get you can print them off at
the com with this car all you have to do
is show you my number c no no no it's
it's like it's like a printer it's on
the printer an attachment on the printer
you put it on so if you ever need to get
like tax documents you don't need to go
to the City Hall you can just go to a
printer and go through the options and
get all the documents you need to print
yeah and like the jum H is that what
it's called the resident yeah you can
get that as well from the printer so
it's like realized you were supposed to
go to the town hall for that yeah I
haven't even got to I got the one right
and it's this beautiful certificate and
you they're like oh can we see it and
then they take it and I'm like no oh
yeah yeah you can't copy it they take it
yeah I didn't realize you're supposed to
go to the town hall to get new one you
to pay $4 for them to print this [__]
thing off I don't know why and it's on
some very special paper with the biggest
QR code I've ever seen on the B it looks
like a mess uh yeah it's very annoying
though but just doing anything in the
town hall is never fun and and never
gets easy all right so I'm not alone
there at least no no no you you'll never
feel wel It's Kind it's kind of like the
DMV of Japan and the DMV of Japan is
also bad well it depends on which one
you go to it's it depends on the branch
but every town hall experience I've had
is that I've had to wait at least like
even if it's like super empty book out
your morning and afternoon yeah
basically you you waste half of a day
doing it yeah have you renewed your
license yet in Japan uh which which one
the driving license oh that place yeah
no I don't need to do that yet but when
you that place you have to do a 2hour
lecture no I saw that [__] that I
remember see you do you just sit in a
2hour lecture of them talking it's like
a really old guy just pointing at sign
saying don't Drunk and Drive don't don't
don't drive too fast on snow two hours
and then you just get to leave and you
get your license it's ridiculous so
point I heard they have like I don't
know if this is true but I heard they
had like a bunch of foreigners crashing
cars in the videos uh I I didn't a video
it was a presentation but it's like some
weird propaganda yeah I don't know I was
like what the [__] the worst place in
Japan is where you have to reply for the
Visa oh the immigration that's like hell
on Earth well because they they it's
like also in like the worst parts of
Tokyo and there's nothing around there's
like no stop shops there's no [__]
train station near cargo after cargo
like where the [__] am I what is this I
didn't know there were sketchy places in
Tokyo like yeah that place is [__] and
then they got it next to like all the
dangerous chemical plants like yeah yeah
you see people scribbling like I hate
Japan on like the on the tables and [__]
like that so depressing dude Jesus the
town hall is great though they're super
friendly the what the town hall actually
the town hall yeah uh it depends I guess
a lucky Town yeah Town Hall luy Town
Lucky Spa the one I live at now is NI
shiny Town Hall well the one the one
that we used to live at was a major
major area in CA so it was it was a like
a [__] like 12
stories but the one I love Now is really
small and it's there's no one ever there
there's no lines I'm like yes the small
ones are way better than the massive
ones for sure was fun I do prefer it now
it's way more chill so see I feel like
you have ACC knowing knowing the fact
that like you're going to the
immigration office going to the town
hall getting documents is all the
biggest pain in the house in the world
that I would call that acclamation God
does the Japanese not have anything
better to do fing papers all day like
godamn you are finding out that no they
do not have anything economy could soar
through
the
F yeah and like also everything's always
different so if you need to if you
change addess right you need to go to
the new town hall and tell them that you
change dress which can be a little bit
of a j no no you first have to go to
your old town
hallister break up you got to break up
with you got to break up with your old
girlfriend to get with your new
girlfriend and then and then oh wouldn't
it be great I don't know if my driving
license could also be updated in the
same town hall no you have to go to the
police station to then change on the
back of your uh your driving license to
get them to put the new address why the
police station because the police
station manages all the driving licenses
which is separate but why wouldn't you
put it all in one why do I have to go to
two separate [__] places to do this
this ridiculous what is this that you've
just Googled flying car we would be we
would be driving in these if they all
had it all in one system they want to
put this for 2025 Osaka has like this
bum guy they like a big this is a
helicopter dude that is a helicopter but
but the thing is they they probably
won't make it because it's too much like
legalities to go through it's just a
it's a giant drone it's just a big drone
I'm going to be so pissed if flying cars
come out like right after I die or
something just get a helicopter do do we
want flying cars yes I mean cuz he hates
traffic who does it it's going to be
flying car traffic I don't mind traffic
what the [__] actually no that's that's
that's the weird wa wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay listen listen
daily daily you tell me cut through all
of it that we were in a rush okay that's
different like daily traffic you know 5
10 minutes traffic it's slowed down for
maybe five minutes I don't give a [__]
about that if it's like an hour jam and
I'm stuck yeah that [__] sucks but
like this guy this one car stops in
front of him he's
like it's like but internally
yes but on the outside I'm a good person
I I I I can I can feel when you miss the
red light like you're the last car to
miss the red light I can feel your blood
pressure Rising dude do you like driving
yeah yeah I drive here I love it driving
in Japan is fun I do like driving in
Japan a lot of people you know I think
one thing that is massively underrated
is driving in Japan because a lot of
people you know the trains are amazing
and definitely do use them that does
feel like pay to win yeah everyone
everyone takes public service so the
roads are all clear it's great it's
great because there's so many there's so
many cool areas of can and so many cool
things you just cannot access that a car
definely and I think you know if you if
you don't mind driving definitely do it
if you you know maybe like second or
third trip in Japan look into it it's
it's really fun just don't drive in
Tokyo cuz that's a nightmare it's not
even that bad it's not even that bad
London is so much worse yeah oh I've I
wouldn't even like wish that upon my
worst enemy Lon I got my [__] I got my
license in London it's [__] awful
yeah he was like okay so this this
Junction's a funny one um it's a it's a
reverse roundabout with a one-way system
uh and if you go into the car you get
executed by 1930s law I'm like what what
the [__] is this like the road's not
even paved he's like yeah that's a
feature and then like the random taxes
you get if you're too big of a vehicle
in a certain Road or something I I don't
know how it works I just got a
bill same here all like taking some kind
of roads and there's a congestion charge
I didn't know that tolls in the UK what
the [__] you have to go through the toll
and then go home after go online yeah
and then say hey I was on the toll I'll
pay it with my credit card who thought
of that system yeah and if you don't pay
it you get and if because you know maybe
you're going to meet your family you
forget to you know you forget about it
cuz I my first thought isn't like I want
to pay this bill yeah uh you forget
about it you get fined out the ass for
being late why would you not just like
that's like going to a restaurant and
you having to pay once you got home I
think I think cuz they want to fine you
they want to get fines cuz that they can
pick so much money I mean it's more like
efficient cuz you don't have like a like
you know a gate or Tollgate where people
like lined up still [__] slow but
yeah it's still [__] slow but so many
times I've had a toll and I didn't know
I needed to pay until I got back and
they were like you are late and you have
to pay £300 uh because I saw like one
sign that says you need to pay and I was
like well I I've already D driven past
it so I don't know any of the details
that I needed to do you're driving it's
not like you can write down a note like
on your phone or something like yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah it's kind of
dumb whereas in Japan they just have the
ETC card which is really nice yeah just
rock up that is nice that is very nice
that just sounds like a scam it is a
scam it AB totally a scam [__] up
every [__] toll is a scam oh damn
it's kind of like American Healthcare
like after you're done like here's the
bill by the way yeah took care of it
don't worry about it you owe us three
limbs we were in a coma and the interest
was
crazy started on inflation God damn